Yeah, folks.
Last time I'm going to ask this question
and it's more to get you going than
anything else.
Okay, so
how many of you have not picked a
company yet?
Why are you pointing at her?
Right?
So, uh
if you haven't picked a company,
please do.
And here's the reason. Next Monday, we
have no class.
I'm sure you have big plans for
President's Day,
but this is a freebie holiday, right? No
obligations, nothing to do. You don't
have to call your mother.
It's not Mother's Day. You don't have to
go meet with family. It's not
Thanksgiving Day. I'm not even sure what
I'm supposed to do on President's Day,
but here's what I'd like you to do.
Pick a company.
Get started, right? So, we won't have a
class class the next Wednesday and I
will operate in the safe assumption that
by the time you come back next
Wednesday, you will have a company.
Today, we're going to continue our talk
about equity risk premiums, right?
Because that's the thing you're going to
compute for your company, the equity
risk premium for your company. And I
laid the agenda for estimating equity
risk premium starting with the
traditional way, the status quo way,
which is to look backwards, historical
risk premiums. Assume that things will
revert back to the way they used to be
and I explained why I feel uncomfortable
with it. If you're comfortable with it,
by all means, use historical premium. I
I don't think it's a safe place to be.
But then I built on top of that, right?
Estimating equity risk premiums for
other countries.
Today, I want to go back to that first
step.
Is there a better way to estimate equity
risk premiums that's more dynamic, more
forward-looking than that approach we
talked about last session?
So, I'm going to start by laying out
what I'm going to try to do and then I'm
going to show you what it looks like
right now when I try to do this and why
I think this is a much richer, much
better way to think about implied
think about equity risk premiums.
Let's suppose you go out and buy the S&P
500 today. Inflation is throwing off
things a little bit, but it's at about
6,000.
Right?
You pay 6,000, you get the S&P 500.
Whatever you bought, you bought the 500
largest market cap stocks
in the US.
Why are you doing it? Because you want
to make money, but let's get more
explicit. When you buy those 500
companies, presumably you're going to
get cash flows from the holdings you
have in those companies, right?
So, these are stocks. The traditional
way in which those cash flows came to
you were
What was the traditional way?
Dividends.
But over the last 30 years, companies in
the US have increasingly shifted away
from dividends to buybacks. In my
corporate finance class, we talked a lot
about why that shift happened, but it's
it it this isn't some passing phase. It
is permanent
and it's only going to get stronger
across the world.
I think of buybacks as flexible
dividends.
Yeah.
This is the the start of the class tests
are always at the So, when you look at
each session, there's a start of the
class test. So, the start of the class
test is always separated from the
packet. So, the packet is the same
packet, valuation packet one. So, every
class will start with a test, which
won't be in any packet because it's just
four pages or three pages, but if you go
to the webcast page for the class, it'll
always be at the top, right? So, you can
download the page. So, this is really
not meant to stick very long because
it's really to get you prepared for
what's coming in the valuation packet.
So, you bought stocks, you get
dividends. The The only thing about
dividends and buybacks is I can't tell
you what they will be in the future, but
I can tell you what they were in the
last 12 months.
It's public information. It's called the
statement of cash flows. You add up the
dividends of every company, buybacks.
So, I have know what you paid for
stocks. I know what the cash flows were
last year.
But you don't live in last year's cash
flows. You want expected cash flows in
the future.
What will cause the cash flows to
change? If earnings go up
or your payout ratio changes, the amount
you return changes, your cash flows can
be different. So, let's say I can
navigate that minefield, come up with
expected earnings in future years. And
remember, this is the S&P 500, the most
tracked and followed index on the face
of the earth.
I've got the index level. I now have
expected cash flows. For how long will I
get these cash flows?
These are stocks. They can go on and on
and on forever.
I don't have the patience to go on
forever, but there's also a math
problem. These are the 500 largest
market cap companies.
They can't keep growing earnings at a
rate faster than the economy
because the model will start to blow up
the economy will start to blow up. So,
at the end of year five, I assume that
the cash flows will start to grow at the
same rate as the economy for the rest of
forever.
So, you see what the structure is,
right? You have the index level, you've
got expected cash flows the next five
years, and after year five, your cash
flows grow forever at constant rate.
Michael?
Wait, the
would it be like the same way the S&P
would or do you take the individual cash
flows of the 500 companies?
The S&P is a market cap weighted index.
So, whatever you do has to follow that
same rule because your initial
investment. So, when you buy the S&P 500
right now, what are the seven stocks
that are going to take up about 25% of
your portfolio? It's going to be the
Magnificent Seven and that's going to be
the same thing, your earnings, your cash
flows. So, that number actually, if you
you don't have to compute by yourself
because the S&P 500 actually S&P does it
for you because they do the same
tracking on earnings and cash flows.
But if you download it from for yourself
and you just add up the dollar values,
you're in effect getting a
weighted value, right? So, it it will
take care of itself, but it has to be a
weighted cash flow.
Last step, I ask what discount rate
makes the present value of my cash flows
equal to the level of the index. This is
the question I'm asking, right?
You're paid for stocks. You didn't tell
me what you wanted to make, but given
what you paid and your cash flows, this
is the return you can expect to make.
I'm almost there. That's my expected
return on stocks. You subtract out the
T-bond rate from that,
you've got an implied equity risk
premium. Why implied? Because I got it
from the index. Will it change
over time? Forget about over time. Is it
different now than it was at the start
of today?
What's the one number in the equation
that changes every moment of every day?
The price of the index and the T-bond
rate. Those are moving targets. The
earnings and the cash flows are more
sticky.
But the index level changes, your equity
risk premium changes and in the right
direction. You know what I mean by the
right direction? This morning, we woke
up to some bad inflation news. So, what
did the market do?
Drop.
My equity risk premium get gets
readjusted. So, I'm going to show you
the numbers.
So, I'm going to start with pure
intuitive questions.
I'm taking the index level, the cash
flows, computing an implied equity risk
premium. What if I told you that stocks
are up 20%?
The index level has gone up 20%. What
should happen to my implied equity risk
premium? I'll give you the choices. Go
up,
go down,
remain the same, or you need more
information to ask the question answer
the question. What do you think of this?
So, first, if if I hold everything else
constant, let's take the easy case and
it goes up. What will happen to my
equity risk premium?
It goes down because when bond prices go
up, interest rates go down, same
phenomenon.
If my stock price is up 20%, earnings
are also up 20%,
then what happens? My risk premium's
going to be roughly where it was.
If my stock price is up 20%, but
earnings are up 40%, my risk premium
could actually go up because So, you
see, it'll depend on what hap When it's
not what stocks do that drives the
equity risk premium, it's what stocks do
relative to earnings.
It's a dynamic number. Everything
changes. Earnings and cash flows might
not change every moment of every day,
but they do change over time and you're
trying to compute that steady state.
Let's say you have a crisis. Say, "What
crisis?" Been one rolling around every
year, right? It's only a question of
time.
What happens in a crisis? Stock prices
collapse essentially in short periods.
So, when stock prices collapse,
what should happen to the equity risk
premium?
Should go up.
And that's exactly what you should
expect in a crisis, right? We now have a
dynamic number that reflects what you
feel in your gut.
So, today we're going to compute an
implied equity risk premium. I'm going
to show you what it's look like over
time. I'm going to show you what it what
happens to it during a crisis. But, I
now have a mechanism for computing the
price of risk in the equity market
on an ongoing basis.
Right? You can actually set up your you
know if you want to do this and and it
rings your bell, you want you're good
with Python or with you can actually set
it up. So, the implied equity risk
premium so, you know that ticker in the
top, the Wall Street Journal ticker, you
replace it with your implied equity risk
premium ticker. Because it'll reflect
whatever's happening in the market and
gets recomputed every moment of every
day.
So, let's go back to where I left you on
in the packet. Now,
we are in the packet. So, from this
point on for the rest of the class,
we'll always be on the packet. So,
that's I'm glad that question got asked
because
you're going to notice start of every
class there'll be this packet that comes
out of nowhere. You say, "Where did that
come from?" Three or four page test,
that's always going to be on the webcast
page for this class. Not on Brightspace
because as I told you after the first
session, I'm not going back to that
place
till the very end of the class. It'll be
on the web page so, you can you can
download.
So, I left you with this way of thinking
about equity risk premiums by country,
right? So, you need to remind me again.
So, if I wanted an equity risk premium
of a com- of a country, where do I
start? What's the process I went
through? First of all, I think the
easiest we can do is look at the rating.
Before I do that though, I need to get
something nailed down. I get a risk
premium for the US, right? So, we start
with that. And then you look at the
rating.
Okay, let's keep going. So, you've got
the rating, then what?
You have the then you can do like risk
premium of
the risk free rate of the US. No, no,
before we do that with the rating, I
have to convert into something before I
can use it.
So, you you have to convert rating to
like
Default spread, basically. And then you
scale that default spread up for the
additional risk of equities and then you
add it to the US, right? And you do this
with every country. And if you don't
have a rating,
then you wave your hands and you try to
come up with a country risk score and
try to come up with the risk premium.
Now, part of you as we went through this
process probably said, "Thank God I am
going to go work in New York or London.
I don't have to deal with this crap."
Well, guess what? It's going to track
you down.
So, today's session I want to talk
about, you know, what you know, so with
the different ways of thinking about
equity risk premium, how a company's
exposure to equity risk comes about.
Again, let's talk about the status quo.
And I don't like status quo right now is
you tell me where you're incorporated, I
give you the equity risk premium of the
country you're incorporated in.
So, you're a Turkish company, you're
dead in the water, right? I don't care
what you do, I'm going to give you the
equity risk premium for Turkey, which is
large and you got to live with it. If
you're an Indian company, get the Indian
equity risk premium. And if you're a US
company,
you coast, right? US equity risk
premium.
I've never understood the logic of doing
this.
If you're a German company, you get 100%
of your revenues from Afghanistan,
are you really a German company?
If you're a South African company and
your mine and your gold comes out of
mines in South Africa and you list in
London, have you become a safer company?
In what universe is this even possible?
So, here's the first fork in the road we
come to. Do we look at the country of
incorporation or do you look at where a
company does business?
Now, I follow the where the company does
business side because that's where risk
comes from, where do you operate?
And of course there's nuance here,
right? How do you measure how you know,
where a company does business? You could
take the lazy way out. And often the
only way of available given information
look at where the revenues come from.
Right?
That's a one metric that companies
do break down by a country or by region.
And you can say, "Okay, I'm going to
take a weighted average of where you
operate." And for a big chunk of
companies, that's going to be fine.
But, can you think of companies where
looking at revenues could get you into
trouble?
Yeah, like mines in another country and
Well, if you're a natural resource
company, already you're saying, "Who
cares where the revenues are, right? My
mines are all in South Africa. I could
be selling the gold in in Australia and
the US, but I have to get the gold out
of the ground first. So, with natural
resource companies, it's not revenues,
it's production.
Could both matter? Some companies you
could say, "Well, some of this is coming
from where my factories are and some of
it and we'll talk about ways in which
you can decide how to weight them." But,
you can already see that one approach is
not going to work for every company.
There's some companies where revenues
are all you care about, some where you
look at only production, some will look
at both. And then you trying to bring it
into your equity risk premium.
So, let's let's take the revenue case,
right? I've taken two examples here.
Now, first is Embraer and the second is
Ambev. Both Brazilian companies with
very different kinds of exposures. The
first is a 2004 calculation did for
Embraer. It's probably not that
different now in terms of breakdown.
Embraer is a Bra- Brazilian aerospace
company and a very good one. In fact, if
you've taken any short haul jets in the
US, you're probably either flying a
Bombardier or an Embraer. So, these uh
passenger aircraft with 25, 30, 35
people on.
In 2004, Embraer got 97% of its revenues
in the US and Western Europe. Developed
markets with mature market premiums, 3%
in Brazil.
If I base it purely on revenues, the
equity risk premium for Embraer is going
to look very much like a US company with
all of its revenues in the US.
The one catch though and this should
worry you is where are Embraer's
factories all based?
They're in Brazil. So, Brazil go to hell
in a handbasket, the aircraft are not
coming out. So, you could argue that I'm
probably understating the risk of
Embraer by just focusing on revenues.
But, for the moment, you know why I
focused just on revenues? Because that's
the only information I was actually able
to find, which is public information.
Embraer didn't break down what their
production was. You'd have you could
figure it out, but it wasn't.
The second company is a company called
Ambev. Ambev started as a Brazilian beer
company,
became a Latin American beer company and
now is part of the Ambev empire. Ambev
is the largest brewer in the world.
So, the 2011 valuation of Ambev where I
looked at their revenues and they'd
broken it down by country and you can
see it's now a Latin American company.
It's a Brazilian company that gets
revenues all over.
Mercado Libre, which is this, you know,
online Latin American retailer. You look
at the breakdown, it's a Latin American
company.
So, I take a weighted average.
These are numbers that are public
information. You don't go you don't have
rese- you don't need research. It's in
the public documents.
The only problem is
countries companies are kind of casual
about how they break the world down.
US companies are among the worst.
You know how they break revenues down?
72% in the US, 28% in the rest of the
world. Come on, guys. That's a big space
out there. Could we start to get a
little more specific?
Or sometimes with European companies
there's a there's a different way in
which they frustrate you. They say, you
know, they they break the revenues down.
You know, 31% in Germany,
69% from EMEA.
You know what EMEA stands for?
Europe, Middle East, North Africa. Okay,
guys, you bundle three parts of the
world together with very different risk
profiles. You're saying, "What do I do
if that happens?"
You take what you can get, right?
You can estimate an equity risk premium
for EMEA and guess what? It's going to
be more you know, more Europe than the
Middle East and Africa simply because
so, you look at GDP. You make your best
judgments. But, that's the starting
point. You can use revenues.
Coca-Cola has regional breakdowns. Now,
yeah.
Well, listen, we we're still saying with
revenues. We'll talk about it because in
each of these cases, I'm ignoring the
production, right? With Ambev, with with
Embraer, now with Coca-Cola. I'm going
to argue that I'm worried less about
Coca-Cola and Ambev than with Embraer
and I'll talk about why. But, production
is always this this wild card we're not
even talking about. Partly because the
information is not there, but you're
saying,
"What if that breaks down?"
Or supply chains now, right? Remember in
2020, your supply chain was only as
strong as its weakest link.
And if that weakest link was going
through a part of the world where
everything had broken down, you never
got the supply chain going.
With Coca-Cola, they break the revenues
down by region. And I don't blame them.
If they broke it down by country, this
would run to 72 lines and 72 countries.
One of the reasons if you go back and
look at my equity risk premium map for
the world, I compute those regional
weighted averages
is because of companies like Coca-Cola
where things are broken down by region.
So, take what you can get with revenues
and it's probably one metric you can get
in computing an equity risk premium.
But, it is going to be an issue and I
think Adil brought up the point, "Where
is my production coming from?" You're
not factoring it in. And the other is
I'm taking this equity risk premium
multiplying by a beta. You're saying,
"So, what?" Well, beta was designed to
cap- measure risk against all kinds of
macroeconomic risk factors, interest
rates, inflation. I'm asking you to
carry one more burden, right?
And there's an argument to be made that
country risk is very different from all
of those other risks.
And we talk about what?
So, I want to address those two
questions. What if production is where
your risk comes from? How do you bring
it in the process?
And is there something other than beta
you can use to scale up country risk?
So, let's start with
the companies. And I think it was this
was already brought up in natural
resource company, mining company, and
oil company. Who cares where you sell
your stuff? You sell it to a global
market. It's where you get the stuff
that matters.
This is Royal Dutch in 2015.
Oil and gas company.
And they break down in their annual
report. Again, this wasn't research on
my part. This is actually in their in
their filing. They break down where they
get their oil and gas.
And you know what? The equity risk
premium for Royal Dutch was higher than
the equity risk premium they're using
for many emerging market companies.
And the reason is simple. Oil is in the
riskiest parts of the world. And by the
time you factor in where you get the
oil, the equity risk premium goes up.
So, you can have two oil companies.
One is entirely shale oil based in the
US.
And the other gets half its oil from
Venezuela, and the other half from
Russia. They're both oil companies,
both based in the US, but you're going
to get very different equity risk
premiums.
So, those are the two extremes, right?
You can have all revenues, all
production.
Let me go back to why I was less
concerned about production with the
Coca-Cola than I was with an Embraer.
You know the gross margins
for You first you know what a gross
margin measures, right? It measures the
cost of making the next unit of stuff.
What is the gross margin for Coca-Cola
look like?
What is it? That soda can you bought
for, I don't know, $1.50, $2 out there,
which Coca-Cola might have sold for 80
cents. What do you think it cost them to
make that?
It's all that cost must be the can,
right?
What's in it is this
sugar water with a bunch of flavoring
thrown in and
carbonated.
The gross margins for for brand name
beverage companies is 85 and 90%. What
does that mean? Your production costs
are a tiny fraction of your revenues.
Now do you see why I'm not that that
worried about the production side for
Coca-Cola?
It's fixable,
right?
Conversely, though, when you look at
Embraer,
even if they're insanely efficient,
they're not making 80. I think their
gross margin is closer to 30%. One very
simple indicator of how much you should
be worried about your your production
side is look at gross margins.
Brand name companies, you're less
worried about production than you are
about revenues.
And you can then use those as a basis
for weights. You can bring in both sides
of the equation. How much Where do I get
my revenues? Where do I get my
production? And the weights will be
based on Now, what do my gross margins
look like and how much should I care?
This is not a black and white scenario,
is it? Use revenues, you can use both,
and you have to make your best judgment
on which one will work for your company.
Any questions on waiting to get an
equity risk premium?
Yes.
With the production
scenario that we saw, could this also be
a factor that for mining company you
cannot really move your production?
That's actually That's a good point to
make is the more mobile your production
is,
the less you worry about where you
produce things, right? Infosys might get
all of its software written in a
building in Bangalore,
right?
Let's say
India goes to hell in a handbasket.
They can take all of those people, put
them on three
jumbo jets if they're still around, take
them to some island in the middle of the
Indian Ocean, give them Wi-Fi,
and your production is back online,
right? Tata Motors is concerned,
can't exactly move its factories
overnight. And of course, if you're an
oil company, you're kind of stuck,
right?
So, mobility is good and that's part of
why I'm going to bring in the lambda
factor, because lambda Look, it you can
already see there are layers that you
have to worry about.
So, let me talk a little bit about
lambdas.
It's a It's a measure I concocted.
Notice the word I used. I didn't derive
it because it suggests deep thought.
I concocted on a long flight to Brazil
about 20 years ago.
It was an overnight flight, a red eye I
was taking out of New York. I was
supposed to teach the next two days in
São Paulo.
And I had a person on the the next seat
who was oozing into my seat, making it
very difficult for me to fall asleep. I
had nothing to do.
So, I started reviewing the slides I was
going to use for the next day.
At that time I was doing what the
conventional practice was, treat all
Brazilian companies as equally exposed
to Brazilian country risk.
And the two companies I was looking at
were I think Embraer and Embratel.
Embraer, of course, is the aerospace
company. Embratel at that time was the
monopoly phone company for Brazil. It
got 100% of its revenues in Brazil. I
was treating them both as Brazilian
companies, giving them that big country
risk premium and a big cost of equity.
And about a third of the way into the
flight, I said, "This doesn't make
sense."
I was probably woozy at that stage.
Yeah.
I should be treating them differently. I
should be treating And I said, "I need
to come up with something that gives
Embraer a lower cost of equity than
Embratel."
So, that's when I said, "Be nice to have
something that looks like a beta that I
can multiply by the country risk
premium." Looks like a beta what? And a
a number that scaled around one. So,
when that number is below one, you're
less exposed to country risk. Above one,
you're more exposed to country risk.
And I decided to title that measure
lambda. Why? Because attaching a Greek
alphabet makes it much more difficult
people to critique you. Sounds like you
did a lot of deep thought.
So, I called it lambda. And I landed in
Brazil.
I was exhausted, but I taught all day.
And a midway through the day I come up
with this, and I throw this idea out.
And some person in the front row, who's
I think trying to make trouble, says,
"That's nice, but how do you plan to
measure lambda?"
And I said, "I don't know. I have a long
flight back.
And I'll think about it then." And on
the long flight back, I came up with
multiple things I could look at to
measure lambda.
What are the things that will affect
exposure to country risk?
First,
you could hedge or insure some country
risk, right?
So, if a company is exposed to country
risk and it's hedged it or insured it, I
should give it a lower lambda
than a company that does. It of course
requires me accessing country risk. So,
when I was thinking about it, I said,
"Let's assume I had access to whatever
information I wanted, what would I ask
for?"
I also wondered what happens when a
company is classified as being in the
national interest.
In every country there are companies in
the The minute that happens, your
country risk just doubled.
Why? Because the government just feels
then the incentive to step in and say,
"You can't do that to that company."
So, national interest companies start to
factor into the lambda. So, I made a
list of things
that I would like to know. And then I
would look through an annual report to
see how many of those things I could get
data on. And the answer was
companies give you none of that
information.
So, I said, "What can I do with public
information to come up with the lambda?"
So, I started simplistic. What's the one
metric I said companies routinely break
down? Revenues, right? So, I'm going to
give you a revenue-based estimate of
lambda.
So,
I'm going to take two Indian companies,
Tata Motors and Tata Consulting
Services, both part of the same family
group in India, both Indian companies,
very different profiles in terms of
where they get their revenues.
So, a while back,
you know, Tata Motors at that time was
getting about 92% of its revenues in
India. That number is now down to 70%.
You know why?
Because Jaguar Land Rover has grown much
faster than domestic Tata Motors and has
become a larger slice.
91%. Tata Consulting Services got about
8% of its revenues in India.
Already you can see the divergence.
But I want to convert this into a number
that looks like a lambda, right?
So, I took the average Indian company,
which gets about 80% of its revenues in
India, and I divided
each of the numbers, 91 and 8, by that
80. It's extraordinarily simplistic way
of getting lambda. But if I do that, the
lambda that I get for Tata Motors is
1.14. What does that tell me? Tata
Motors is more exposed to country risk
than the typical Indian company,
whereas TCS is much less exposed.
Confession, I'm basing it entirely on
revenues. So, all the weaknesses that
revenues have.
So, I said, "Maybe there's a more
composite thing I can look at which
captures the rest of the story as well."
Do you remember how you estimate betas
the traditional way? What What do we do?
Run a regression of returns on the stock
against returns on the market index,
right? What is the beta measure? It
measures how sensitive your stock is to
movements in the equity index.
What am I trying to capture here with
lambda? I'm trying to capture how
sensitive a company is to country risk
movements, right?
So, I'll tell you what I tried.
It was a mess. It took me a while. I
will never do it again. All right.
Is I took the returns on Embraer and
Embratel. This is after I got back.
Couldn't do it on the plane because my
Wi-Fi is obviously non-existent then.
I landed. I pulled up the returns, I
think monthly returns, for both Embraer
and Embratel.
Then I also pulled up the monthly
returns on a C bond. You know what a C
bond is?
It's a Brazilian dollar denominated
bond.
Why are you looking at this?
Remember when you with country risk when
a country gets riskier, what what should
happen to the price of If so, Brazil is
viewed as riskier, what should happen to
the uh the price of the the C bond?
It'll go down. The return of the table
So, basically, the return of the C bond
becomes a proxy for country risk. Cuz
what goes into C bond, right? Since it's
a dollar base rate, is the T bond rate,
which has nothing to do with Brazil,
plus a country risk premium that the
market is assessing.
I ran that regression. The slope of the
line, what does that tell me? It tells
me how sensitive Embraer and Embratel
stock prices are to changes in country
risk.
Take this with a grain of salt because
there's a big standard error on each of
these coefficients.
If you look at the regression I got for
Embraer, every 1%
return on the C bond, up or down,
Embraer is up only 0.27%.
Makes sense, right? Less exposure to
country risk, the market reflects that.
In contrast, Embratel, which has
everything in Brazil, and it's in the
national interest, right? It's a it's a
monopoly company.
The lambda I get is two.
I'll have to confess to you lambdas are
incredibly painful to compute. I almost
never use them unless I have a company
with a singular country risk exposure
that I'm really concerned with. Nigerian
company and I'm saying Nigerian country
risk is a big country risk, then it
might be worth doing it. Otherwise, go
the weighted equity risk premium
approach. Don't do this with Coca-Cola.
Do you really want to estimate 72
lambdas? Maybe you do. I don't.
It's a painful process, but essentially,
it allows you to
So, I'm going to bring this all together
because I've thrown all these different
ways of estimating equity risk and so,
which one should I use?
I'm going to kind of try to converge on
the big choice I made.
I took Embraer and I computed five
different costs of equity.
In each of them, I did didn't all in US
dollars because in 2004, there were no
10-year
Brazilian real denominated bonds. So,
desperation drives me to the risk
premium. So, that's why you see the 4%.
Leave the beta as is for the moment.
We'll come back and talk about how do
you get a beta for a Brazilian aerospace
company?
And the differences came primarily from
two things. One is
whether I viewed Embraer as a Brazilian
company and attached the entire country
risk premium for Brazil, which was 7.89%
then,
to the cost of equity, in which case I
get 16, 17% as my cost of equity.
Or whether I treat Embraer as a company
that gets all a lot of its revenue. So,
whether I use a lambda or whether I use
a weighted average equity risk premium,
that's going to give me a much lower
number, 9%, 10%.
You see what the big choice here was?
You If you decide to treat
Embraer as a Brazilian company, you made
the big choice. You're going to come up
with a much higher cost of equity than
me.
So, when you ask me, should I use
lambdas, should I use weighted averages,
you're already playing on my side of
saying your number's not going to be
that different. I'm going to say do
whatever you want to do and move on
because you already made the big choice.
The big choice was not giving Embraer a
Brazilian equity risk premium because
it's a Brazilian company. Yeah.
Very close, right? Because if your beta
is pretty close
If you look at the weights, 97% come So,
it it's just a math works out, right?
That's why I said those within those
approaches, once you made that choice,
the numbers are not that different.
So, let's step back, right?
I've made the argument, and you might
disagree with that, that a company's
risk exposure should come from where it
does business.
But there is this view in the world that
a company's risk exposure comes from the
country itself.
The market make can pick whatever it
wants. Which one do you think the market
goes with most of the time?
It goes with the whichever country
you're in.
You're an Indian company, you're an
Indian company.
And you know what it's worse is when you
have a crisis,
which Indian stocks get sold?
All Indian stocks.
I mean, right now, India is going
through a little bit of a crisis. I've
been blamed for it over the weekend. I
don't know how I entered the
conversation now, right?
I take no responsibility for it. It's
down like 15%. And everything is being
sold. TCS, yeah.
Clearly, markets are not that
discriminating, right? And And if you
agree with me that country risk comes
from where you operate, they are pushing
down the prices
of these companies too much. Which
companies? The TCS's, the Infosys of the
world by treating them as Indian
companies.
Let's let's carry that forward.
If you believe that markets
systematically make this mistake
of treating all Indian companies as, you
know, giving them the same and pushing
down the prices of even companies that
should have
What will that mean as an investor for
you? Which companies are going to look
undervalued to you and which ones are
going to look overvalued?
So, you look at an emerging market like
India
after a correction like the correction
we've had, which ones are you going to
buy? Julian, what do you think you'd
buy?
Would you buy the companies which have
less exposure to India or more exposure
to India?
Less exposure.
And then you get down on your knees and
you have to hope and pray that what
happens?
That markets eventually come around to
your point of view.
What's the guarantee? None. I mean,
markets can do whatever they want.
But I have adopted over the last I have
a list of every
And you can try this out. Come up with
your own list. Go to each market, pick a
company or two just like Embraer.
Right? Company that is in that market
but gets a bulk of its revenues outside.
Vietnam, it could be Vinamilk. In
Turkey, it could be Turkish Air.
Right?
And then what you do is you sit and
watch. What are you waiting for? A
crisis. You say, what if there's no
crisis? Trust me, there will be one.
It's not a question of whether, it's a
question of when.
And then make it automated, right?
Because you decide then you're going to
make the buy decision, you will hold
back. Right?
Essentially, put in a buy order. I
actually bought Embraer for the first
time after Lula won election for the
very first time in Brazil.
And you're probably too young to
remember when he first won election, but
when he first won election, people were
convinced that as he was a communist, he
was going to nationalize everything, the
markets completely imploded, and
everything got sold off, including
Embraer.
Right? Eventually, the truth came out.
You know what causes the truth to come
out?
Not some sage speaking or a blog post.
It's after the crisis, Embraer continues
to report earnings, right?
It still has its long-term contracts.
So, even though the rest of the market
is melting down, they're able to report
good earnings. And after about the third
earnings report, investors wake up and
say, "Maybe it's not that Brazilian a
company.
Its numbers look pretty good." That's
what you're hoping for as your
correction.
So, think about this because it is
actually a interesting way of thinking
about the divergences that are being
created within markets.
So, now we're ready to talk about
implied equity risk premiums. So, I've
set up the process, right? It's an
internal rate of return. Yes.
When you say
this is happening in Brazil, but it's
highly dollarized, I don't know what to
call it. Don't use the word dollarized.
Like it's a you it's a Oil companies
really I your risk comes from where you
get the oil, right? There's no dancing
around. There's So, Petrobras might sell
all of its oil into an oil market, but
if as long as the oil comes from Brazil
and its reserves are all in Brazil, it's
going to be completely exposed to
country risk. It's very difficult to
escape country risk. So, Aramco, where
does it sell its oil?
I mean, everywhere, right?
It's for about 30% of the oil in any
given day could come from Aramco. But in
our valued Aramco, and that was a
valuation of the week, the equity risk
premium I used was just Saudi Arabia's
equity risk premium.
Because everything rides on where you
get your oil.
I thought you were going to ask me a
different question because I talked
about how emerging market companies with
a lot of developed market exposure tend
to get undervalued.
Do you see the flip side of that in
developed markets? What kinds of
companies are going to get overvalued?
US companies with a lot of overseas
exposure, right? You think, "That's a US
company." And you know, Coca-Cola, you
wake up, there's a Russia crisis, and
then we act surprised.
What's the surprise?
You get 30%, 25%, 50% of your revenues
from emerging markets, it's Again, the
surprise is going to happen. You're
trying to build that in proactively into
the required rate of return.
So, let's talk about this. Yes, go
ahead,
Jenna.
Um the top principle of like oil
companies, their risk on them is tied to
where they're actually getting their oil
from. Is that true for companies that
like the fine arts? Like most companies
that supply natural resources or
something like that? Any natural
resource company, you're kind of trapped
by nature, right?
If
an LVMH example, who's
operations are very tied to No, but now
we've left the natural resource. There's
nothing that LVMH does that's natural,
right? So, let's get that out of the
way, right? Everything is concocted, so
it's whether it's cosmetics or lipstick
or whatever else you sell, or it's all
made. So, there's a manufacturing
facility. What's the number you're going
to look at to see how much you have to
worry about the production costs at
LVMH? I kind of talked about it as a
gross margin.
You know how much uh I don't know, you
know, I I can't tell but Gucci for
instance, you know how much the actual
Gucci bag costs Gucci to make?
Barely more than what a Canal Street guy
spends on making a Gucci, right? It's
not like you have high-end incredible
materials.
It's marked up to a thousand dollars.
So, if you're looking at Gucci, I
frankly couldn't care where you make.
You might actually end up buying the
stuff on Canal Street and actually
selling it in an actual Gucci and I
wouldn't even notice, right? There I'm
going to argue it's all about revenues.
But if you are a company that's like
Temu, which just marks up your margins
at three, five, seven percent, I'm much
more concerned about where does all
that's a mystery to me because you can
buy all kinds of things on Temu and you
say, "Where do these things get made?" I
never kind of a clue, but I don't want
to dig any deeper.
It's going to be more about where is the
factories because that's what's going to
drive it. So, again, it's a common sense
way of saying, I mean, the way I like to
think about it is if you're a manager at
this company, what keeps you up at
night?
Right?
And if you're a Coca-Cola, I guarantee
it's not your cost structure in your
factories that are keeping you up. It's
your branding, it's your advertising,
it's what people pay as a premium.
Right? If you're an oil company, the
only thing you think about all day long
and all night long is
my oil's all in Kazakhstan and Nigeria.
How the heck am I going to get it out of
the ground?
So, that's actually a good way of
thinking about it. Put yourself in the
shoes of a manager in the company and
say, "What would drive you know, what
what what gives me nightmares?"
And then bring it into the process. Yes.
Yeah.
transportation Yeah, that's it. So,
you've added another layer, right? You
got the oil out of the ground in
Nigeria, you got to get it onto ships
and the ships you got to get the oil to
So, there and the it's got to go through
the canals which have now been stopped.
That's a So, you can actually argue that
there's a third dimension here, which is
the supply chain dimension.
Which after 2020 might be a factor. You
might actually have said, "That's where
my risk lies."
But now we have the mechanism for doing
this. I would look at the countries your
supply chain goes through and bring it
into your equity risk premium. But we're
now talking that's a healthy discussion
of risk rather than say, "Tell me where
you're incorporated." Okay, that's your
equity risk premium.
So, let's set up
the implied equity risk premium
approach. You already saw the basis,
right? It's an internal rate of return.
There's no theory, no model, it's
completely model agnostic. You tell me
what you pay, I back out the internal
rate of return, which effectively means
that when you get scared, you push down
prices, I come up with a higher premium.
And then I come up with an implied
premium. It's dynamic, it's constantly
changed.
I set it up at least in the abstract.
This is the page you saw already as part
of the the test today.
But when you look at it, there are no
numbers in there, right? So, let me show
you what the numbers look like on
January 1st, 2020.
I was getting ready for my 2020
valuation class.
I think this this year is going to be
easy.
Right?
Doing this for 34 year 30 plus years,
how difficult can it be? And I compute
an implied equity risk premium January
1st. Index was at 3231.
Expected cash flows, I took the
dividends and buybacks in the most
recent year projecting them out. After
year five, I assumed that the cash flows
would grow at 1.92% a year. That sounds
oddly precise. You're saying, "Where the
heck did you come up with the 1.92%?"
It's my risk creator.
It's you're going to see me use this
trick all the time in valuation. When
you get to steady state, the best
estimate you can get for your nominal
growth rate is your risk creator.
And I'll show you the tables that back
it up. You can ask macroeconomists, you
can ask the T-bond.
And the T-bond's always right.
I have the cash flows, I solve for that.
I In Excel, I used to solve for or the
goal seek function because it's a messy
equation to solve.
I get an expected return of 7.12%.
What does that tell me? At the start of
2020, people were pricing stocks to earn
7.12%.
The T-bond rate was 1.92%. So, before
you say that looks low, 7.12, your your
alternative is to invest in something
risk free at 1.92. That difference
is 5.2%. That's what I started 2020 at.
February, I recompute I do this start of
every month, I recomputed the number,
very close to 5.2.
Here's February 14th, I'm still in a
state of complete denial.
This is virus, but it's all in China and
cruise ships. Why should I worry about
it?
And then we woke up and on February 14th
to a new story from Italy. Remember
that? That the Italian government had
found COVID
in Italy from people who never been on a
cruise ship or to China.
And the nightmare began.
That's February 14th through March 20th.
Six weeks. If that, five weeks.
Take a look at what the equity risk
premium So, I actually that year, I
tortured myself
by computing the implied equity risk
premium at the start of every day.
I had nothing else to do. I was stuck at
home anyway, right?
Might as well spend some of the time you
know,
rather than learn to cook or something
which is you know, bake, which is a
complete waste of time. I said, "I'll
compute the implied equity risk premium
every day."
And there it is, right?
In a five-week period, the implied
equity risk premium went from about four
and a half percent to five percent all
the way to eight percent.
Don't ask me what happened.
You were there.
You knew what happened, right? I don't
think people remember how terrifying it
was
in terms of what was coming. In
hindsight, we put it all the I knew
everything was going to be okay. I knew
a vaccine would be developed by
November. I knew the economy Really?
I kept a journal through that entire
year to remind myself of what the things
that were happening then and how scared
I was because in hindsight, it's amazing
how you can paper the sun.
What made this crisis different than
previous? The same thing happened in
2008. I kept track from September 12th
to December 31st of that year every day.
It actually is a way you can keep
yourself sane because in a crisis, you
know what else happens, right? You
listen to people telling you the world
is ending and the next thing you know,
you've done all the wrong things. This
keeps me kind of grounded. It's okay,
it's okay. I can compute an implied
equity risk premium still.
What In the 2008 crisis though, you got
hit 8% November 20th, I think of 2008.
And that number did not come back to
pre-2008 numbers for about six years.
You know what's different about 2020?
There's a crisis, by September, it's
almost like the market said,
"Huh? It's over."
And in fact, the market was at odds with
experts, right?
Cuz experts had vaccine will not come
for two or three years at least. No
vaccine has ever been developed this
quickly.
And the economy is going to crash and
burn. And the market said, "No, I don't
think so."
You know, in the last four years, every
time there's been a contest between the
market and experts, who wins?
Look at this. Market was right.
I mean, last year during the election, I
list I read Nate Silver's polls and I
read the what did the New York Times
column writing in the New York Times.
And then I followed Kashi.
You guys ever follow Kashi? It's this
marketplace where they actually allowed
you to trade Trump and Kamala Harris
votes.
And it did a much better job all the way
through at predicting what was going to
happen.
So, the equity Now, the advantage of
doing this is if you did this with a
with a historical premium, I could not
do this, right? Because all it is, it
stays the same. I'm in the middle of the
worst crisis. It's like having a blood
pressure gauge on you that always tells
you you're okay, 110 over 70 and your
blood pressure is shooting through 240
or on the verge of having a heart
attack, it says, "No, you're okay."
An implied premium gives you It might be
noisy, but it's giving you an updated
number.
So, at the start of 2025,
we're now getting closer to today.
The market was at 5881.
I compute an implied premium again. So,
if you look at the expected return, it's
8.91%.
That's better than the 7.12% you saw in
2020, right?
But what else has changed?
The risk free rate is now 4.58%. Your
opportunity has become more lucrative in
terms of not investing in stock. That
difference
gives me an implied equity risk premium
of 4.33%.
February, that number is down a little
bit because stocks are up you know, a
little bit to 4.27%.
Here's the way this plays out in my
valuations. All of the valuations I did
in January 2020 and I probably valued
about five companies.
My equity risk premium for the US and
mature markets was 4.33%.
This This month I valued two companies,
Anka, the Turkish company.
I revalued LVMH. And this This month I
am using 4.27% because
What will I be using in March? I don't
know.
But it will reflect what the market
looks like. It makes me live in the
market I'm in, not the market I wished I
was in.
Kind of forces you to ground yourself.
So, any questions about the mechanics
and what what I'm trying to do here? Go
ahead.
The period before the earnings year, how
are you calculating earnings growth for
that period?
The period before the earnings year.
Basically, what happens is I get two I
can get two years of forecasted earnings
from analysts or maybe at the best three
years for the S&P 500.
So, I do the three years, the actual
earnings numbers, right? From the
analysts because they give you the they
make the predictions.
And then I know my growth rate is going
to be 4.58%
after year five. All I do is I go and
linear step. So basically if it was 7%
or 8% for the first 3 years, I go 8%,
6.something percent. So it's essentially
bringing it down. And to be quite
honest, if you finesse it, it's not
going to make much of a difference. The
bigger thing is what you assume. So
that's the smoothing out effect I do to
get down. So I don't want it
dramatically drop to 4.58% in year five.
And it's
in terms of how much it matters and what
my final equity risk premium is, it's
about third or fourth on the list. It's
not the big deal. The big deal is that
leading number. The dividends and
buybacks are already 4% of the index.
That's your starting point. So your
index is going to be you know the equity
risk premium is going to reflect those
cash flows.
Yeah.
You know, you said you live in the
market that you're in, but when we did
our first assignment that you you left
That I left you. So basically you got to
separate what you're doing. So if I ask
you to value Coca-Cola, you got to live
in the market you're in because what am
I asking you? You know, how you have
conditional expectations? I'm asking you
for a conditional valuation. Given where
the market is today, is Coca-Cola cheap
or expensive?
So let's say you answer the question.
Then I say,
"What do you think about the market
today?" You know, the reason I separated
the two questions, the answer to the
second question drives my asset
allocation decision.
So if I think the market is overvalued,
what should I do?
Invest less in equities, more in bonds.
But within that less in equities, I'm
now going to come back and say, "I'm
going to invest in only 20% equities,
which company should I buy?" That
question is really a conditional
expectations question. So I want you to
separate the two. It's not that I don't
want you to have a view. In fact, that's
what going to be my next step. You look
at the 4.33%
and you ask, "Is that enough?"
We're in bubble territory now, right? In
terms of not in terms of market being
there, but in terms of people talking
about bubble. So we've been bubble
territory for the last 10 years. So
we're surrounded by bubblers.
Right?
And the basis for the bubble I don't
have a problem with you me telling me
the market's in a bubble, but what's the
core
factor driving people to tell you we're
in a bubble?
What what is what
There's more bubble talk now than maybe
10 years ago. Why is there more bubble
talk? Price earnings is higher. One is
the price earnings ratio is high. That's
a favorite metric, right? PE ratio is
23. What else?
For the first time the equity risk
premium Which is another way of flipping
it. You flip the earnings with price
earnings, you get an earnings yield,
it's less than the T-bond, right,
Michael? Inversion of the yield curve.
Inversion.
That that the yield curve is now back to
being very mildly positive. If you
squinted, it looks like it's going up.
It used to be going down. But also we've
come off two really good years for
stocks. Let's face it. When you have
two, three, the longer you have good
times,
the more you say, "Okay, maybe
the party's going to stop."
So I understand people are anxious,
they're worried. But this can't be the
basis for saying the market is in a
bubble, right?
Because then you'd have been out of
stocks in 2016, 2017, 2000 There have
been There are people who've been out of
stocks since 2013.
Because they feel the market's in a
bubble.
So we've got to do this with a little
more discipline.
I think the equity risk premium gives
you a way of framing whether the market
is in a bubble.
So let's take a look at the equity risk
premium. 4.33% right now, right? You
think that's too low or too high?
You think you're okay with 4.33%?
I've been looking at the chart. You're
looking at the chart, right? And I'll
tell you what the chart says. This is
the implied equity risk premium of the
S&P 500 going back to 1960. The average
across the last 64 years is 4.25%.
So you should go to bed comfortable,
right?
But then it throws you a curve. If you
look at post-2008, which I said divides
the world up, pre-2008,
the implied equity risk premium's been
closer to five and a quarter.
Now do you see why you can disagree
about the market? But those
disagreements are really about Should
the fair equity risk premium be 4.25%
or 4.25% the market's fairly valued. If
it's 5.something percent, what are you
telling me? The market is overvalued.
So really the question becomes, are we
looking at a number that is so low
that I don't believe it?
This graph actually kind of gives you a
point in time where you look at the
numbers and say, "No way." Even though
you were finding ways to invest in
stocks.
Right?
Jesus.
So this is implied equity risk premium
going back in the US. You can see the
1970s. Implied equity risk premium pops
through the roof. What caused it to do
that? Inflation.
Right? Inflation is deadly for stocks.
And you see that play out in a little
piece today, right? 3% What happens
next?
1978, you know what the Dow was at?
750.
There were three numbers in the Dow.
We're at 30-something thousand,
40,000.
I remember Business Week headline in
1978 said, "Stocks are dead."
What does that tell you?
Whenever the financial
news gets on tell you stocks are dead,
it's time to buy stocks like they're
going out of style. Because between 1978
and 1999, you had one of the great bull
markets of all time. Remember the equity
risk premium is going up, stock prices
are going down.
The equity risk premium's going down,
stock In fact, you put in the dot-com
boom. By the end of 1999, the implied
equity risk premium in the US I remember
my 2000 class,
I presented 2% equity risk premium.
T-bond rate was 6 and 1/2%. I was
offering you 2% more. And I said, "How
many of you take a 2% premium?" And
I had to to a person, every person in
the class said, "I won't." And then he
said, "How many of you are invested in
stocks?"
And they were all fully invested in
stocks.
Why? They said, "The world has changed.
There will never be another recession
again
because of the internet."
I mean, that's In fact, there was a view
that the world had shifted. Of course,
in hindsight, it was wrong. We bounced
back to 4 and 1/2%. 2% is definitely
bubble territory.
4.33%, we're in that gray area, right?
You can say stocks are expensive because
you're getting a low risk premium
relative to the last 15 years,
but this isn't sell everything head for
the hills kind of risk premium.
The reason I track the equity risk
premium by month
is I want to know when I'm in a bubble,
not after the fact,
but while it's happening. And this gives
me a device.
You're saying, "How is this different
from using a price earnings ratio?"
What's the first price earnings ratios?
We'll come back and address but what is
the
If I use the PE ratio as my only metric,
what am I missing? What are the things?
Let's take the last decade. PE ratios
are higher than they've ever been.
But what was also true about the last
decade that explained those high PE
ratios?
Not just growth rate. The T-bond rate
was really low, right?
So the fix for that was to take the
earnings to price ratio and compare the
T-bond rate, which is what the Financial
Times and Wall Street Journal did a few
weeks ago and said stocks are in a
bubble.
Now you brought in the T-bond rate.
You're using the earnings to price
ratio, but you're using last year's
earnings. You're ignoring growth, you're
ignoring cash flows, the fact that they
can change.
It's a very very very blunt instrument
to decide stocks are cheap or expensive.
And equity risk premium is just a
dressed-up PE ratio, right? Because I'm
bringing in the PE ratio, it's in there.
I'm bringing in growth, I'm bringing in
cash flows, I'm bringing the T-bond
rate.
Because I want to be able to tell you
that I have control for those things
before I give you this number.
So I will send you my February 2025
implied premium spreadsheet. It's a very
simple spreadsheet. You can update it
with today's S&P 500, today's T-bond
rate, run the goal seek, you'll get the
implied number.
You have a way of updating your equity
risk premium. So you don't need me to
publish this on my webpage. There are
people actually email me and say, "You
haven't published it. It's February It's
March 3rd and you haven't put your
The spreadsheet is there. Do it
yourself. I'm not feeling like doing it
right now, you know? I'm in Disneyland,
you know?
So do it yourself. Make it your
spreadsheet.
Modify it, adapt it, adjust it. Because
you can see what I'm doing is not rocket
science.
So with that implied premium, there are
a couple of interesting follow-up
questions that I wanted to answer.
Here's the first one. This implied
premium, 4.33%, is on a 4.58% risk-free
rate.
The implied premium of 5.2% in 2020 was
on a 1.92% risk-free rate. You see where
I'm going?
What if the risk-free rate goes to 10%
or 12% or 15%?
My question is, will the equity risk
premium have to get larger? Because now
you have earning on top of something
So to answer that question, I looked at
T-bond rates
starting in 1960 going through And for
the equity risk premium went up. I was
wanting to find out if when T-bond rates
are higher, equity This is a purely
empirical question. We can dance
ourselves around. And the answer in the
US is there's not much relationship
between the level of rates and the risk
premium, except in the 1970s.
So how would I read that? If inflation
truly becomes 7, 8, 9%, I would expect
equity risk premiums to go up. But
three, two, three even three and a half
percent, we can live with that, right?
Equity risk premiums.
But if you ask me to estimate an equity
risk premium for Turkey, if I start with
a 21 and 1/2 percent risk-free rate,
I might say, "Look, you know, I'm I'll
settle for a 6% premium if risk-free
rate is 3%, but at 21 and 1/2 percent,
that's got to be a much higher number
cuz I'm building off a much bigger
base."
There's a second question I wanted to
answer. Equity risk premium is the price
of risk in the equity market.
But there's another big market out
there, the bond market, the corporate
bond market. Is there a price of risk in
the in the corporate bond market?
What's it called?
It's called a default spread, right?
Just like the equity risk premium
changes all the time.
So, when people get scared in one
market, are they getting scared in the
other market?
It's often the same people, right? How
can you say, "I'm terrified of the
equity market, I'm feeling okay in the
corporate bond market?" So, I wanted to
see what the price of risk in the bond
market did and look at whether it moved
with the price of risk in the equity
market. So, in this graph, the red line
is the implied equity risk premium. The
black line is the spread on a BAA rated
bond. That's an investment-grade bond,
so it's a pretty safe bond.
And you can see that default spread also
varies across time. Most of the time,
the two move together. But there have
been two periods in the last 30 years
where the two have moved in different
directions.
And if you'd pay if you'd been paying
attention, it might have saved you some
trouble. Let's take the first one.
There's the 1990s dot-com boom.
What's happening? The equity risk
premium keeps dropping and dropping and
dropping. It's down to 2%. The default
spread actually stays intact. In 1999,
you were actually earning a higher
spread on a BAA rated bond than buying
equities as a class.
So, if you were an investor and you were
actually looking at these two numbers
and you were making decisions from
scratch and rationally,
where should your money all be invested?
It should be invested in bonds because
why would you want to expose yourself to
the risk of equities if you're making
This is an investment-grade bond.
Of course, people weren't listening.
We'll talk about why this was this
comparison wasn't jumping out at people.
Then you move to 2001. Of course, 9/11
happens and Alan Greenspan says, "I will
not allow the US economy to go into a
recession." The hubris of central
banking.
And he tried, right? The way he tried
was he essentially pumped money into the
bond market, effectively pushing down
default spreads. There's a
the Greenspan effect.
But the equity risk premium stayed where
it was. So, now you're in 2006, your
default spreads on bonds have dropped to
historically low levels.
You can earn a reasonable equity risk
premium still. You can see that the
reverse of what you did in 1999 would
happen.
And of course, when you push default
spreads to low, think about the
consequences. What's happening? As
lenders, you're charging too low an
interest rate to cover what? The
defaults that will come.
Reality doesn't wait for theory to catch
up. In 2008, reality caught up, which is
defaults started coming and you hadn't
charged enough of a default spread.
I describe 2008. Most market crises in
the last century have been caused by
equity investors behaving badly.
2008 was caused
by bondholders and banks behaving badly.
Collectively, that's at the heart of
almost everything that went wrong.
You're saying, "What about the subprime
crisis?" What's the subprime crisis?
Somebody describe that to me. What was
it?
And Jagrati, would you remember what the
subprime crisis was?
What's subprime first?
Risky
borrowers, right?
Can you build a business lending to
risky borrowers?
Yes, as long as you do what?
Charge a higher interest rate. Come on,
money lenders have been around for 5 800
years lending to risky borrowers
and they've been a pretty It's been a
pretty lucrative business to be in. You
know, the problem with 2008 was not that
you were lending to risky borrowers, but
you were lending to risky borrowers and
charging them investment-grade rates.
That never ends well.
And of course, that correction led to
2008.
You're saying, "That obvious in this
graph, why weren't people catching on?"
Because
we end up with tunnel vision once you go
into markets.
Many of you have jobs lined up, I hope.
But your job is going to be either an
equity job or a fixed income job, right?
And if you end up with an equity job,
guess what you focus on? Equity. Equity
You don't even You don't have lunch with
the fixed income guys. They're strange.
You hang out with your own tribe.
And the fixed income guys are the equity
guys are very flighty and speculative. I
don't want to hang out with them.
No.
It's me to the bone. Each market kind of
is insulated from what's happening in
the other market. One reason I started
doing this was I wanted to see what
these two markets are doing because
there is information in there. One of
the few things that I think hedge funds,
especially macro hedge funds, bring to
the picture is they step back from the
fray. They can look at different
markets.
And so, you know what? This market looks
cheap, this market looks expensive.
And essentially try to take advantage of
the mispricing.
So, you got equity markets, price of
risk is the equity risk premium. Bond
market is the default spread. And if you
in real estate,
you were in real estate? Doesn't matter.
You know, wherever you were in real
estate, there's one number that drives
how much you Were you in real estate,
Ria? Okay.
You're a tech person, right? Tech real
estate. WeWork, right? That could be
real estate version. Right?
But in real estate, there's one number
that determines how much you pay for a
building.
It's called a cap rate. What's a cap
rate? I don't know why real estate wants
to invent terms
when you have terms already out there. A
cap cap rate for a for lack of better,
it's like a cost of equity.
That's basically what it is. They call
it a cap rate. Here's how a cap rate
works. Let's say you're a building with
a million dollars in rental income and
you want to decide how much to pay for
it. If your cap rate is 10%,
you'll pay a million divided by 0.10,
which is $10 million. If your cap rate
is 8%, you'll pay 12 and 1/2 million. If
it becomes 5%, you pay 20 million. So,
you can already see that as you lower
the cap rate. Cap rates are driven by
risk by greed and fear, just like the
other one. So, when people get terrified
in the real estate market, what happens?
Cap rates go up, the price of real
estate drop.
So, I went looking for cap rates over
time to see how cap rates moved. Now I'm
getting really messy. I have three
different markets here. The red is my
equity risk premium. The black is the
bond default spread and the green is my
real estate risk premium and it looks a
little strange, right? Especially
in the two decades toward the end of the
last century.
It's actually negative.
Why would you invest in an asset class
with expected returns that are lower
than what you can essentially make even
on a risk-free investment?
Why would you do that? First, you can
say these people are crazy, the real
estate developers driving the prices,
they don't you know.
That could be an answer, but there's
another one. I when I did my MBA,
one of the big lessons that was conveyed
to people is,
you know, real estate as an asset class
is a good thing to invest in if your
money is primarily in financial assets.
And what was the logic driving why you
should invest in real estate?
Oh, because you would be protected if
the financial It doesn't move with
financial assets. That real estate moves
on its own. That's slightly or even
negatively correlated
with financial assets. 1970s,
stocks horrific decade, worst decade in
history. Bonds even worse.
You know, the only two only two asset
classes that held their value? One was
gold
cuz it does well with inflation. The
other was real estate.
So, they said, "Go buy real estate." And
if something is negatively correlated,
that's like having a negative beta,
right? So, the asset class should in
fact have a return lower than the
risk-free rate.
So, they sold us all on investing in
real estate. But investing in real
estate comes with a problem, right? It's
lumpy.
What does that mean? You have to buy a
house or an office building. It costs
tens of millions of dollars. Even an
investor with 2 million to invest, how
the heck are you going to add real
estate to your portfolio?
So, what did Wall Street do in the
1980s, starting with Lew Ranieri?
They securitized real estate.
They met a demand, right? Now you could
buy real estate as an individual
investor either in the fixed income side
or the equity side by buying
And came with a side effect that I don't
think we think about when we think about
securitizing everything.
As we securitized real estate, it
started to behave more and more like
stocks and bonds. You know how this
manifests itself, right? 2008 was a
terrible year for stocks.
The terrible year for real estate. It
was a good year for bonds.
2020, bad year for every all three.
What you now get is in years when your
financial assets are doing badly, your
real estate is also doing badly. And
this is
horrifically bad news for investors.
Why? Because we all as investors need a
safe place.
There are no safe It used to be in the
'80s, the safe place was go to a foreign
market.
They don't move with the US or buy real
estate.
That doesn't move. Where are you You're
to go?
Every crisis, I turn off my phone.
Cuz people I don't know, distant
relatives who
can you tell me a safe place to put my
money?
I feel like saying put it put all it you
know convert all into cash put in a
brown paper bag just mail it to me.
And maybe you'll see it if a couple of
years from now maybe you won't. There
are no safe places that which is why
every crisis now feels more terrifying.
You can sell things but where are you
going to put the money?
So in a sense you can see this play out
in asset class and that's again the
advantage you get once you make you
couldn't do this with historic risk
premiums but you can see it with implied
premiums.
So I've been selling this idea of an
implied premium now for 30 years with
mixed success.
So I'll tell you how this usually goes.
You go into you know go talk to equity
research analyst and investment bank.
The managing director will say you know
what you know this implied premium
sounds good but we're okay. So what do
you mean you're okay? They say we all
use the same premium.
And as long as we use the same premium
what does it matter whether the premium
is right or wrong?
As long as the same premium. Let's play
it out. Let's assume you're the managing
director of an equity research group.
You all decide to use an 8.44% premium
that came from the historical risk
premium stocks versus TV. Pick a just
random number out of that table 8. And
everybody in your group uses 8.44%. The
implied premium is 4.33%.
So tell me what you're going to find
each of you as you value company using
an 8.44% premium the market's premium is
4.33%.
Paola what's every person in this group
going to find when they value companies?
You So you have a higher risk premium
than you should. What's that going to do
to your discount rates?
They're going to make it higher to push
down the value of every company. So
company A is going to look overvalued.
Company B is going to look overvalued.
Company C is going to look overvalued.
8.44%
I can almost guarantee you that nothing
in the US equity market is going to look
cheap to you.
So what are you going to do? Put sell
recommendation sell recommendation sell
recommendation next day you're fired.
Why? You're an equity research analyst
you can't be doing that.
So you know what analysts end up doing
right? Because this happens all the time
when investment banks impose an equity
risk premium that is higher than the
current implied premium.
You need to put buy recommendations. You
can't do much with the discount rate
because it's already been pushed up.
So what do you do? You play games and
that's the only way to describe it with
your growth rates and your cash flows.
You make up growth rates. You push them
up until you find enough
There's no really no point doing
intrinsic valuation once you start going
down that road but this is exactly where
it starts.
So wherever you go to work if you're
something to do with valuation ask them
what the equity risk premium is. Compute
your own implied equity risk premium.
It's a pretty close.
Just let it go right? You don't have to
impose your premium. If it's much higher
you might have want to bring that up as
an issue where overestimating the cost
of equity and capital for every company
that we value.
And our job is to value companies.
We can And if you go the other direction
everything will look undervalued right?
You use too low a premium.
So even if an enterprise doesn't use
implied premiums knowing what it is will
give you some insight into why you're
struggling so much trying to find
undervalued companies.
Like there is this mythology that
intrinsic valuation most companies are
going to look overvalued.
Because the market's so high.
What should your answer be to that?
If you're building an implied premium
that reflects where the market is
in intrinsic valuation you should get
balanced right?
If everything is overvalued you can't
blame the discount rate. That's not
where the problem lies there has to be
something about your forecasting cash
flows and growth that's driving it.
It brings the focus back on where it
should be.
Stories and cash flows and growth.
So every year I write this I started in
2008 for the
no 2009 for the first time.
I write this I'm I was going to call it
a magnum opus but if this is my magnum
opus I am deep trouble.
I I write this thing on everything I
know about equity risk premiums and I
won't even call it a paper but it's a
practitioner piece.
But it starts with historical premium so
it takes you takes you through all these
processes and at the end I say look
No it's you said no she said he said we
all come up with different ways of
estimating equity risk premiums but
there's a test to see whether the equity
risk premium you're using is a good one
which is if you do this right the equity
risk premium you come up with should be
a good forecast of what the actual
returns are in the following time
period.
So I said that's a testable proposition.
I can use historical premiums. I can use
the earnings to price ratio.
I can use the the default spread and
multiply by roughly two.
So I take all of these different equity
and I run a I run a race where I look to
see which measure gives me the best
predictive power
for future returns.
So what do I want if I'm running a
correlation what do I want to see?
A high positive correlation right?
So I've taken four the
rest didn't even make the list but let's
take four.
You can take the current implied
premium.
Right now it's 4.27%. You can smooth it
out. You can take an average implied
premium which is a little higher 4.4
4.5%. You can use a historical risk
premium which is right now 5.44%.
You can even take the default spread
which right now is about 1.6 or 1.8%
multiply by two roughly speaking that's
what it's been historically.
And then I run the correlation. So let's
start with the worst possible way to
estimate equity risk premiums.
What am I looking for? A large positive
number.
This is about as terrible an estimate as
you can get a historical risk premium.
Not only is it the wrong sign it's
cutting all the way. So if you want to
perverse estimate of equity risk
premiums keep using historical premiums.
It's going to cut in the wrong direction
it's going to give you a high numbers
when you should be using low low numbers
when you should be using high and 90% of
world
runs on historical risk premiums.
I was agnostic when I did this as to
which implied premium. I used to kind of
experiment with
averaging out smoothing out because you
feel this thing I I'm smart I can figure
out what what noise is.
And when you look at the numbers it kind
of brought me down to earth saying just
use the current implied premium. You
know?
And you can see it on every measure you
know one year returns five year returns
10 year returns
the current implied premium
does as well or better job than any of
the other numbers.
So when people say why aren't you using
earnings price? Put that in the mix see
what it does right?
Essentially you're letting the market
tell.
One final point for today and this is
where I'm going to end the day and I
don't want this to end up on YouTube as
my diatribe against Indian equity so
don't put it you know
It'll end up in the actual video people
might splice it anyway.
Implied premium.
What do I need? I need the index level.
I need cash flows and I need a growth
rate right?
Can I get that for any market? Yeah. I
don't need any history.
So this was a 2007 estimate I'll tell
you what the 2025 number looks like
where I tried to compute the implied
equity risk premium for the Sensex.
Took the level of the index.
Took the cash flows which are actually I
used it I had to estimate the
took just the dividends you know the
problem with Indian stocks is not much
in buybacks and you can use free cash
flow to equity if you feel the urge to
do it.
But make your best judgment. The growth
rate was messy.
Cuz unlike the S&P 500 where there are
analysts forecasting earnings as far as
I could tell there were no analysts in
India who forecast earnings for the
entire Sensex. They forecast for
individual companies and for many of the
companies they'd only one year forecast.
Companies which had ADRs listed them
trading in you were able So I spliced
and diced together different growth
rates and ended up with a growth rate of
14% all in rupee terms.
The risk free rate in rupees was 6.76%.
I did exactly what I did with the S&P
500 as the index level there are cash
flows solve for the expected return. The
IRR in India in 2007 was 11.18%.
Subtract other risk free rate
the equity risk premium in India was two
was 4.42% negative.
You know what that number looks like at
the start of this year in India?
What's the Sensex day done since 2007
you think?
Quadrupled maybe?
I know that the India story working the
background and that push up growth. I
put all of that in. I even gave it a 10
year growth rate because India is a much
more growth before it settles in.
The implied equity risk premium I came
up for India was about three to three
and a half percent.
Let's step back right? US premium is
4.33%.
You could probably add German stocks and
earn a 4 and a half percent premium.
As a global investor
you can tell me all the stories you want
about India but if you're offering me a
three and a half percent premium I'm
saying why would I invest in India?
That raised an interesting question. Why
would Indians invest in India?
Because you have no choice.
It's true Indian investors you know as
an Indian as a US investor I don't like
the way US stocks are priced. You know
what I can do? I can pull all my money
out of US stocks, buy ETFs in Germany
and you know, Europe wherever else I
want. I can move my money around.
If you're an Indian investor, you don't
like the way Indian stocks are priced,
where are you going to go?
I think there's a escape hatch which at
least exists now, didn't exist 20 years
ago, $250,000 you can take out of the
country. You've got to jump through all
kinds of regulatory hoops.
But the rest of the money stays in
India.
And China is a very into the same
problem, right? If you're on in mainland
China,
you can't exactly invest wherever you
want without jumping through hoops. And
I think that's all It's actually a
little better now than it was 40 years
ago, but 40 years ago nobody cared
because as an economy India was small,
there wasn't much wealth to invest. You
could put all these barriers in and it's
still
But as both India and China have become
wealthier, this problem is just going to
get bigger and right now it's all this
money with no other place to go.
Buying Asian paint at 55 times earnings,
so that looks cheap to me.
Yeah, because you know, everything is
relative. Yes.
Yes, and there's a reason for that. It
goes back to foreign exchange controls
in the old days where
money left India and you invested in
dollar terms, basically had to convert
your rupees to dollars. So these were
restrictions put in the 1970s, the 1960s
when foreign exchange was such a scarce
resource that you had to hold on to
every dollar you could.
The problem now is not a foreign
exchange issue. It's how do you open
these escape hatches without creating
chaos?
Let's suppose tomorrow
the Indian government removed all
restrictions
and Indian investors went looking for
stocks in Germany, the US. You see,
that's good for Indian investors, but
what do you think of what it means for
the Indian equity market and Indian
companies who've been coddled with now
20 years of really low cost of equity
cuz they've got a captive
market, right?
If I were the Indian government, and I'm
not, thank God for that,
I'd figure out a way to start opening
these And the same thing with the
Chinese This is not going to get better.
It's not going to get easier to fix.
At least start moving in the right
direction and opening up these escape
hatches
because here's the most toxic thing that
comes out of this, right? Even Indians
at some point in time will say, let's
say the premium drops to 3%, 2.8. At
some point he said, this is too low even
for me. So what do you do? You pull your
money out of stocks
and you put it into something else. In
the old days it used to be gold and real
estate, but guess what? They've been run
up as well.
You're going to end up with a lot of
Bitcoin holding Indians if you're not
careful because they're going to go
wherever they can go. It's not healthy.
And it You can see the train wreck
coming, but India and China though have
to do something about that train wreck.
I will talk to you on Wednesday, so you
get a week off, have fun, but pick a
company, work on it while you're on
vacation wherever you are.
Yeah.
Cash returns to your
Yeah, it should be percentage. Yeah, the
cash return should be the Yeah, that's
that's No, no, what I'm saying is The
numbers are off.
Yeah, that equation was wrong. I fixed
it when I read it.
So I should get like 160.
You said you're looking for a group?
Oh, that's good. Yeah, you know me cuz I
might find a company to It's the
See you tomorrow.
So I thought I was The I you were like
Um I did
Yeah, I will.
There's like something like that.
127, you get a discount. It's actually
the Yeah.
You get a discount. We have like
Okay, I think
what I need to do is just to put the You
know, any students want to learn uh it's
literally a joke.
Um I don't know if I'm actually to So
they don't do
So sorry. The core business is one
separate company. Yeah.
this
Oh, it's a private equity that's
considering it in the core business.
But it did publicly trade.
Okay. All right, next one.
Two questions.
Yeah.
How does it make sense for
It's not a question of
US to
If you weren't have the choice
Why would you not have the choice?
Uh for example, I have we have
institutional investors that have a cap.
Yeah.
Yeah, I would
Yeah, very much. No, that's what